[Música]
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con cecilia
alemani directora regional adjunta de
onu mujeres estamos cercanos a
conmemorar el día internacional de la
mujer este próximo 8 de marzo y la
agencia de naciones unidas propone una
alianza regional para la digitalización
de las mujeres lo que se ha denominado
una canasta básica digital
cecilia buen día bienvenida y en qué
consiste esta llamada canasta básica
digital
compartir esta iniciativa y bueno has
estado cubriendo la pandemia todo este
año así que es evidente para tito a la
audiencia que el tipo de ocupaciones que
desempeñan las mujeres en américa latina
y el caribe pero en muchos países en
desarrollo
ha sido en
y aquellos sectores que se han visto más
por esta crisis que ya es social y
económica y no solamente sanitaria y
encontramos junto a la cepa de la
comisión económica para américa latina
que si el nivel de conectividad de los
países y las persistentes brechas de
género y de acceso y uso de tecnologías
que encuentran muchas mujeres en los
países en vías de desarrollo se
corrigieran se corrigieran tendrían
muchas más oportunidades de volver a
trabajar porque una gran pérdida de
empleo y de poder conciliar mejor la
corresponsabilidad de los cuidados del
cuidado de los hijos de las hijas de la
familia que todavía no se distribuye muy
equitativamente en américa latina y el
caribe así que recientemente la semana
pasada en la conferencia regional de las
ministras de américa latina- en cartera
en el gobierno de chile junto con
nosotros son mujeres y sepan lanzó esta
iniciativa
y básicamente busca corregir estas
desigualdades y contribuir con muy pocos
recursos que tendrían que estar
destinando a nuestros países a que todas
esas mujeres que hoy están afuera de la
economía digital que no pueden volver a
un trabajo de tipo virtual puedan
recibir esta canasta básica digital que
tiene una computadora portátil un
teléfono inteligente una tablet y se
tiene que complementar con facilidades
de acceso a datos hemos visto en esta
crisis que muchas mujeres que son
responsables a veces
las únicas responsables económicas de
sus familias la mayoría en situación de
pobreza que tienen que elegir si comprar
comida o datos y bueno esta iniciativa
busca corregir este problema que aumenta
con la crisis se han sumado ya otros
gobiernos en cilia y costa rica y
esperamos que se sumen mucho más perdón
a que la interrumpa pero es que quisiera
abarcar más temas porque esto que usted
nos dice es un reto grandísimo el
objetivo de entregarle a una mujer una
tablet de un teléfono o un computador y
además de acceso a internet pues es
sumamente ambicioso como esperan que los
gobiernos colaboren y además usted están
hablando precisamente de la pandemia no
podemos obviar la realidad del
teletrabajo que no ha quitado sino que
por el contrario ha aumentado las tareas
de cuidado
totalmente si esperamos que los
gobiernos participen de esto más allá de
que puedan también colaborar otros
organismos financieros y de la
cooperación hacen parte ha hecho los
cálculos y en promedio tendrían que
destinar en promedio un 1 por ciento de
su producto bruto interno y esto
permitiría llegar a 4 de cada 10 mujeres
en
todo el continente por ejemplo donde la
brecha de las mujeres que no tienen
acceso digital es relativamente menor
que en otros países de la región con un
0,3 por ciento del producto bruto
interno y llegarían y podrían hacerlo en
un año a un 14 por ciento de estas
mujeres que están realmente sufriendo en
la falta de acceso y de posibilidad de
encontrar un medio de vida y de seguir
trabajando online como muchas tenemos el
privilegio de poder hacerlo bueno
lamentablemente estas iniciativas muchas
veces se encuentran con las barreras de
la burocracia y de la accesibilidad ya
para cerrar quisiera preguntarle por qué
marca la diferencia que una mujer tenga
acceso a la tecnología y por qué la
importancia del cierre de esta brecha
digital de género muy rápidamente
cecilia
primero es que ya sabemos que con esta
crisis retrocedimos 10 años en logros
socioeconómicos de las mujeres en la
región el desempleo es mayor y muchas no
están volviendo de buscar trabajo no
solo porque todavía no hay trabajo sino
porque aumentó su carga de cuidados
hicimos una evaluación rápida en la
región en tres países y 44% de las
respuestas nos decían que ni siquiera
sus hijos habían podido atender a la
escuela en línea por falta de conexión a
internet así que el problema grave el
futuro de trabajo ya llegó pero las
condiciones materiales para nuestros
países todavía no están dadas pues
muchísimas gracias a usted tendremos más
oportunidades de conversar más adelante
y de conmemorar el 'día internacional de
la mujer' sigan con nosotros en france
[Música]